Welcome back everyone they just released the boys
season 3 teaser trailer so we'll break it all
down there's a whole bunch of new characters and a
bunch of easter eggs so if you're brand new to the
channel i'll be doing videos for all the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get them all obviously
they say they're dropping june 3rd but the tagline
for the trailer is payback is coming and even
though they want you to be focused on homelander
having a full mental breakdown in this scene like
the flash of the camera over and over is somehow
going to trigger him into doing something crazy
the payback tagline is a reference to a couple
different things actually a bunch of different
things so in this scene they want you to think
that homelander is planning on getting payback
against the boys for what they did against him
what starlight did because she's here with him
in this press conference that they're doing in
everyone else like the entire human race because
he's completely lost his mind if it wasn't clear
this scene is meant to be happening after the news
conference at the end of season two when they were
throwing stormfront under the bus for all the bad
stuff that had happened like oh yeah stormfront
she did that all by herself screaming i can do
whatever i want just completely nuts like okay
he's lost it that's it he's gone he's totally
crazy everyone hide your kids hide your wife
but the reason why it's just him in starlight
in this news conference here is because they're
hyping them up as the new public faces of the next
roster of the seven team because they're bringing
in fresh meat to join the team in the form of
jensen ackles soldier boy because the whole thing
in season two is that they brought in stormfront
and made her a member of the team now they're
doing the same thing with jensen echols because
they lost stormfront i love how ashley looks like
she's about to crap her pants like she's watching
homelander expecting him to do something she had
it so bad in season two that was why her hair
started falling out from the stress she's kind of
like meg from family guy she's kind of there to be
the punching bag of all the people on the seven
like everybody kind of soft abuses her not just
homelander but all the other characters too but
the payback term is also meant to be a reference
to the payback team from the comics which itself
is a reference to the avengers from the marvel
universe everybody talks about the boys having
lots of dc easter eggs because the seven are meant
to be a parody of the justice league in-homelander
is meant to be like an evil superman but a lot of
the characters from the boys comics are also
parodies of marvel teams and other characters
too jensen eccles soulja boy will be the leader of
the payback team when he shows up in episode one
and the title of episode one is literally
payback this is what his superhero costume is
going to look like they made some changes from
his character in the comics and what they've
done is give him more of a militaristic looking
green armor suit like military green and they've
combined the two different versions of soldier
boy from the comics on the show they're hyping him
up as the original superhero even though that's
just vought's fake backstory for him because
we know that stormfront is actually the very
first superhero in the world but in the comics
the original soldier boy is a straight-up captain
america parody if you couldn't tell during world
war ii he was america's first attempt at their
own superhero with their own version of compound v
formula but the parody aspect of his character
was that unlike captain america he was a terrible
superhero and a terrible soldier he got his
entire squad killed because of his incompetence
in the original boys comics everything is
taking place much earlier in the timeline so
like the war that they say soldier boy came from
might be a little bit different like they might
still say world war ii or they might say that
jensen ackle's version is just the grandson
of the original soldier boy that might be part
of his fake backstory that voc tells everyone
but in the comics there's also a version in
present day called soldier boy 2 who just
basically uses the name and he's like a
brand new compound v superhero who's also
just as incompetent as the original version was
but he leads the payback team the other major
difference with jensen ackles version is that he's
not going to be like this bumbling idiot version
of the character he's going to be way more badass
and he's meant to be more of a foil for homelander
now soldier boy isn't nearly as powerful as
homelander but he's super popular and he knows how
to work the crowd which is basically homelander's
main weakness the idea that he needs people to
love him he is thirsty for everyone's attention
so the smart way that everybody's been trying to
fight him especially at the end of season two is
by using that against him like you're not going
to beat him in a physical one-on-one fight so
you have to beat him in a psychological fight
milk is kind of his kryptonite so you could also
use some sort of milk based plot too but the other
idea with the whole payback notion is the idea
that everybody on the show every main character
every different team on the show is going to get a
form of payback so like stan edgar is going to get
payback against homelander by bringing up soldier
boy the boys themselves are also going to try and
get more payback against homelander homelander
himself is going to try to get payback against the
boys for what they did to him in victoria newman
is also attempting to get a form of payback and
it's part of her whole secret plan they said that
that's actually going to be the largest part of
season three like most of season three will focus
on what's really going on with victoria newman and
what her big secret plan is going to be so you've
probably seen these little mini tie-in episodes
they've been releasing for the boys season three
they're like this mini tie-in content based on a
fake in-universe fox news parody show controlled
by vought like it's vought news network vought
owns the tv network so the news on the station
is just propaganda for the company but in this
seventh and final episode where they released the
boys season 3 teaser trailer they also released a
clip with an in-universe interview with huey about
what he and victoria newman had been doing since
the end of season two to answer your question
the fpsa doesn't hate superheroes far from it
actually we're actually partnering with then why
are you and victoria newman using the fbsa to run
a sham witch hunt against them all we're doing is
holding superheroes accountable for their actions
and since the fbsa began super-related crimes
and collateral damage have seen a significant
decrease if you look at the data victoria newman
is using that new authority that she's been given
to go around arresting evil supers or just
any superhero who breaks the law but remember
she herself is a superhero who murdered alastair
brutally to keep him from causing problems for her
down the road and it seems like none of the
boys themselves or the seven know that she's
a super but the only way to become a super in the
universe of the boys is to get compound v and the
only place to get that is from vought so there
is probably a connection between victoria newman
and vought that i'll talk about in a second
but she is playing a comic book character
she's a version of vic the veep and in the comics
he was a man in the former ceo of vought before
stan edgar he left the company to become vice
president of the united states and it was all
part of vought the company's true goal to control
the white house control the president control the
government early theory is that victoria newman is
working with stan edgar as part of the secret plan
to get vought inside the white house there was a
reference to this in the opening scene from season
2 episode 1 when stan edgar is having a meeting
with jim beaver's character another supernatural
actor like justin ackles where he implies that
he wants to be giving the president orders
my early theory is that victoria newman is totally
a plant and she's trying to make herself look good
enough in the public in the government so that
she'll become popular enough to get voted into
office into the white house as either vice
president or president but again it's all
probably just part of a larger four-dimensional
chess game that stan edgar is playing for too long
members of the superhuman community have played by
their own rules through a joint effort with vought
international we'll work together to see that
heroes who engage in over-aggressive rogue conduct
and unlawful activities are held accountable
to the very same laws that they claim to uphold
cannot wait till huey finds out that his boss is
exactly the thing that he was trying to run away
from the whole reason why he left the boys team at
the end of season two was because he just couldn't
handle all the shady stuff they were doing it off
he runs to victoria newman who turns out is like
the new most shady character on the show remember
all the people in the courthouse she killed all
those people while she was sitting there she
was the one that was popping all those heads
but currently the boys team are still doing the
same old same old trying to keep homelander in
check with maeve's ultimatum and take down the
other worst superheroes like they're not just
after the seven and homelander and fought they
take out as many terrible superheroes as possible
ryan is still in the custody of the black ops
government group run by mallory if you've read
the comics my early theory is that the show runs
for like five or six seasons they'll give ryan a
version of the big black noir versus homelander
ending scene like eventually it will be ryan vs
homelander like superboy vs evil superman very
luke skywalker darth vader if you want to make
a star wars reference they have released the full
episode schedule they're dropping the first three
episodes on the first day just like they did for
season two and then one per week after that and
they really they really want you to remember that
episode six is going to be the herogasm that's
basically like the worst version of a florida
spring break vacation trip but for superheroes
vought's fake cover story is that it's like a
superhero workshop retreat but they really just
all go there to do a bunch of drugs and have
sex with anything that moves the other brand
new superhero characters they're doing in season
three from the comics are crimson countess played
by lori holden another walking dead actress she's
a parody of scarlet witch if you couldn't tell
super sonic is another speedster who's kind of
like a version of kid flash in universe he was
starlight's high school boyfriend so he's just
gonna come back and cause trouble for huey and
starlight there's a new character called blue hawk
that they're doing who is not from the comics and
then there's a character called gunpowder they're
doing who's actually meant to be a parody of judge
dredd so like i said not all the characters are dc
or marvel parodies there might be a couple other
new characters that they haven't announced yet
in the later episodes but the only other new big
superhero team that they might introduce beyond
payback and the seven is the g-men and the g-men
or like another vought-sponsored team meant to be
an evil version of the x-men but on the show they
might just make them a new team who's working for
victoria newman at her agency like she probably
has other superheroes who are good on her payroll
but remember again vac controls all superheroes
so anybody who's working for victoria newman
is actually secretly working for vought
if you did spot any other easter eggs in the
teaser trailer that i didn't talk about in the
video or if you have any questions about season
three just write them below in the comments i will
be doing videos for all the episodes just like
season 2 and i will add a link for all my season
two videos in the description below everyone
click here for that first look at rune king thor
in thor love and thunder and click here for my
new doctor strange multiverse of madness video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!